Ich bin der Dienstabend Arzt, der hier ist.
Ja, gut gemacht.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschiff für Sie damit einversammeln.
Ja gerne, kein Problem.
Ja, okay.
Ja, so erst möchte ich ein paar Irrepersonen in der Tat sein.
Ja, abgemacht.
Nein, irgendwie so, weil ich persönliche Daten nicht hatte ein Problem hat,
ob ich mich über meine Erkrankung mit Ihnen sprechen möchte.
Ja, aber so erst müssen wir Ihren persönlichen Daten um sicher sein.
Ja, vielleicht ja etwas Ungewöhnliche, oder die Patienten verwechselt miteinander.
Deswegen müssen wir...
Sie haben doch meine Namen, oder?
Oder bauen Sie doch mal meine Namen?
Nein, ja, Namen, nur Namen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Friedrich Nauman.
Nauman.
Mit A.O., ja.
Ja, genau, so wie man es ausspricht.
Nauman.
Ja, okay.
Und wer als Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
38 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Oh, haben Sie das nicht?
Hallo.
April 28.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
1904.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Nauman?
Ich bin circa 1,72 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich glaube, 93 kg war ich zuletzt.
93 kg.
Okay, Herr Nauman, was kürztest du uns?
Oha, Doktor.
Ich habe seit heutem Tag starke Schmerzen auf meinem rechten Bein.
Oder eher am Rücken.
Rechte Bein.
Seit heute Mittag?
Seit heute Mittag, ja, ja.
Das hat vor zwei, drei Tagen angefangen, aber seit heute Mittag ist es ganz schlimm.
Ja.
Ich kann kaum stehen.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Rechte Bein hinterher.
Das fängt am Rücken.
Ja, das fängt am Rücken.
Also das fängt am rechten Rücken an und das strahlt so über mein Po über das Bein bis zum Fuß.
Und Fuß, ja?
Ja.
Ich habe schon so viele Medikamente genommen, aber es hilft gar nichts.
Ja, was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ach Gott, ich habe einiges genommen.
Das war über Profäen.
Dann habe ich Paracetamol genommen.
Und heute habe ich noch mal zusätzlich Naualgin genommen extra.
Aber das hat Ihnen nicht geholfen, ja?
Immer nur ganz kurz, halbe Stunde und dann geht es wieder los.
Und wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Siehende, Druckende?
Ach so, es ist mehr so ziehende Schmerzen, ja.
Es ist manchmal wie ein Blitz, ganz schlimm.
Ich kann kaum auf dem Bein stehen.
Und haben Sie diese Beschwerden früher schon einmal gehabt?
Nein, nein, das ist das erste Mal, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen, auch eine Schmerzkala von eins bis zehn,
wobei ein sehr leites Schmerzen und unerdirectes Schmerzen ist?
Seit heute Mittag ist es bei acht, neun, vielleicht sogar zehn,
würde ich sagen, ganz schlimm.
Ja, und haben Sie das Gefühl, Ihre Bein, ja, Taubheizweite,
Taubheizweite oder Kribbeln?
Du meinst, dass mein Bein Taub ist?
Ja.
Ganz Taub, ja, das stimmt, ja, ja.
Und hat Ihr Haut das Bein verändert?
Wie, die Haut, wie meinst du das?
Ja, die Haut des Ihres Bein hat sich verändert, oder?
Ich meine, die Hautfarbe?
Ja, Hautfarbe, ja.
Nein, da habe ich nichts bemerkt, nein.
Und haben Sie das bemerkt, Ihrem Fuß oder Ihrem Bein Kraftverlust?
Kraft, ja klar, ich sage ja vorhin, ich kann kaum stehen,
ich kann auf so einem rechten Fuß kaum laufen, also da ist die Kraft deutlich weniger geworden,
das stimmt schon.
Deswegen bin ich ja bei Ihnen.
Ja, okay, Sie haben sehr entschieden, dass Sie uns gekommen sind.
Und Herr Neumann.
Herr Doktor, nein, wollen Sie noch reden?
Wollen Sie mir nicht etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben?
Das ist ja ganz stimmt.
Ja, können Sie diese Schmerzen auch bis jetzt?
Ich glaube nicht mehr, es ist echt ganz dringend.
Gehen Sie mir etwas gegen die Schmerzen, das ist im Moment ganz schlimm.
Jetzt lege ich bei Ihnen einen Verlustzugang und gebe Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel.
Bitte, was richtig gut ist, also es ist ja kaum auszuhalten, es ist ja furchtbar, bitte.
Ja, okay, jetzt gebe ich Ihnen, ja, das hilft besser, oder?
Ja, noch nicht, aber ich hoffe, dass es jetzt langsam besser wird.
Ja, okay.
Was haben Sie mir gegeben, was ist das?
Ja, starke Analgetik.
Okay, vielleicht.
Und dürfen wir weiter machen?
Ja, bitte, vielen Dank.
Ja, okay.
Ja, gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder persteckt?
Nein, ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe schon verschiedene Schmerztabletten probiert,
aber geholfen hat eigentlich nichts.
Und ja, sind die Schmerzen lagerungsabhängig?
Ja, das ist ja gut.
Man ist es ein bisschen besser, mal im Liegen, aber dann wird es wieder schlimmer.
Ja, egal wie ich mich bewege, das tut alles weh.
Oder beim Hochlagerung ist es auch, ja, immer weh.
Ja, immer weh.
Und wie viele Meter können Sie ohne Schmerzen oder ohne Pong?
Nein, geht gar nicht. Also ich kann kaum stehen, ich kann gar nicht rein.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese Schmerzen.
Ja, damals auch.
Nein, das hat sehr langsam angefangen, dann ging es einigermaßen.
Seit heute Mittag, ganz schlimm.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber, Schutte, Brot oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, das bin ich aufgefallen, Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ich kann kaum schlafen oder ich kann mich gar nicht bewegen wegen den Schmerzen.
Herr Neumann, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewalt abgeholt, zugenommen?
Nein.
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Und ist Ihnen über...
Durch die Medikamente habe ich ein bisschen Mahmungschmerzen.
Ja, wegen Medikamenten.
Oder, ja, ansonsten haben wir nicht...
Ja, okay, sehr schön.
Und ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Einszuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Normalerweise nicht, aber jetzt mit den Schmerzen kann ich kaum schlafen.
Okay.
Herr Neumann, haben Sie irgendeine kronische Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, bisher war alles ganz in Ordnung, ich hatte bisher keine Erkrankungen.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendeine kronische Medikamente?
Normalerweise nehme ich eigentlich keine Medikamente.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch irgendeine Medikamente?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, nein, also habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Oder Lebensmittel?
Nein, nein, nein, natürlich kann alles essen und trinken.
Ja, sehr schön.
Sind Sie gegen Corona geämt?
Ja, ich habe schon drei Info-Lingar.
Ja, drei Info-Lingar.
Und waren Sie schon in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Oder haben Sie einen langen Zeit gereist?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Ich war nur im Sommer jetzt vor sechs Wochen, war ich für ein paar Tage in Italien,
aber das war jetzt nur ganz kurz.
Ganz kurz?
Italien, das ist ja hier.
Ja, mit dem Auto sechs Stunden von hier.
Ja, okay.
Vor sechs Wochen, ja.
Ja, jetzt im Sommer genau.
Aber da hatte ich keine Probleme.
Gut, die Autofahrt war etwas länger, aber sonst war es okay.
Ja, und brauchen Sie, Herr Neimann?
Wir rauchen? Nein.
Nein.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Noch sehr, sehr selten.
Ja, was meinen Sie sehr selten?
Ach, wenn einmal fest ist, oder bei einer Feier,
aber ansonsten gibt es kein Alkohol.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und eine Frage noch, und das müssen Sie auch fragen.
Ja, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Wie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Meine größte Droge ist Schokolade und Kekse.
Ja, das auch.
Und hast Sie Ihre Appetit in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nein, Appetit ist immer gut.
Okay, und haben Sie,
oder gibt es in Ihrer Familie, in Ihrer Verbandschaft, in Ihrer Nähe,
irgendetwas vor Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass Sie gewüscht sind, oder?
Nein, ja.
Sind Ihre Eltern Leben noch?
Ja.
Meine Eltern leben noch, soweit ich weiß,
sind die auch gesund und haben keine Anklankungen.
Ja, das ist schon.
Soweit ich weiß, haben sie auch keine Tabletten.
Ja, haben sie Geschwester?
Ich habe nur noch eine Schwester.
Ja, und ist sie auch gesund?
Sie ist auch gesund.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Gärtner.
Ja, bei dem Garten.
Seit wann?
Sie sind jetzt circa zehn Jahre alt.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Das ist schon ein sehr stressiger Beruf.
Wie viel zu tun?
Wie viel zu tun,
wie viel zu tun?
Das sind schon manchmal zehn bis zwölf Stunden.
Ja, das sind so viele.
Das war auch die letzte Zeit der Arbeit zu viel.
Das kann gut sein.
Wir haben, bevor das mit den Schmerzen losging,
beim letzten Auftrag im Garten,
sehr viele Bäume gesegt.
Und mussten auch schwere Sachen tragen.
Das ist der Anfang.
Und?
Sind Sie oder stehen Sie immer?
Während der Arbeit stehen Sie immer?
Nein.
Wir müssen natürlich immer wieder bücken und Bäumen auf die Kette.
Schwere Äste schleppen.
Oder auch mal Steine tragen.
Das ist schon manchmal sehr schwere Arbeit.
Herr Neumann, treiben Sie Sport?
Soweit ich Zeit habe, ja.
Was treiben Sie?
Was ich mache an Sport.
Ich spiele manchmal Volleyball und manchmal Tennis.
Ja, das wäre schon.
Was mir vor einer Stunde aufgefallen ist,
ich wollte auf Toilette und konnte Urin nicht mehr halten.
Das ist von alleine weggegangen.
Ja, Sie meinen,
Urin nicht bei Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Ja, bei Wasserlassen normalerweise.
Das war ganz komisch.
Ich konnte Urin nicht mehr halten, das läuft von alleine weg.
Ganz komisch.
Haben Sie das bemerkt im Blut im Urin?
Blut habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen, nur dass es einfach weg geht.
Ich kann Urin schlecht halten, das läuft von alleine weg.
Und reichen Sie, oder?
Recht das Urin?
Nein.
Wie immer.
Es ist komisch, dass ich den Urin
nicht mehr halten kann.
Haben Sie noch etwas Beschwerden?
Nein, das ist doch genug.
Das Bein möchte dieses Problem lösen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das zusammenhängt
oder ob das anderes ist.
Das ist eine komische Semptung.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das zusammenhängt.
Das kommt darauf an, dass es anders ist.
Vielleicht.
Wir haben unser Gespräch.
Herr Neumann, ich denke,
ihr habt alle Petige freigestellt.
Ich fände, bitte helfen Sie mir.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus.
Die Intansion hat geholfen.
Ich habe Angst, dass es wieder schlimmer wird.
Schauen Sie nach, was es ist.
Ich verstehe Sie, Herr Neumann.
Das ist eine Schmerzeilhaft.
Das ist eine Schmerzhaft.
Und es ist zu früh etwas zu sagen, aber ich habe einen Verdacht auf ihren Beinen verschlossen.
Ich denke, dass in den Wehnen etwas verschlossen ist.
Ja, es kann sein, aber es muss bestätigt werden.
Was machen Sie da? Wie wollen Sie das bestätigen?
Ja, so erst würde ich gerne körperliche Unterdrückung, danach werde ich bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen und einen Ultraschall Ihre Extremität durchführen.
Ja, vielleicht Topler Ultraschall.
Ultraschall, dann machen Sie schnell.
Ja, nach dieser Unterdrückung werde ich mit meinem Operar besprechen, wie wir heute vorgehen.
Danach gehe ich zurück und rufe Sie wieder auf.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, dann beheil sie sich bitte.
Okay, bis gleich.
Ich habe einen Kollegen an der Frage.
Also, die Diagnose muss man sich sich mal überlegen, ob das geht.
Die Diagnose ist ganz anderes. Sie haben nicht verprugt.
Wenn Sie so etwas denken, dann müssen Sie einfach fragen, haben Sie geschwollene Beine oder...
Ganz anderes, was Sie haben gesagt.
Genau.
Woran denkt man natürlich als erstes, welche Diagnose kommt Ihnen betrachtet?
Genau, also eher...
Wie beschreibt man diese Schmerz, Symptomatik?
Eine Lumboischialgie.
Das komplette rechte Bein tut weh.
Das fängt von Rücken an, der Strahl bis zu Fuß.
Es ist Taub, starke Schmerzen.
Und ganz wichtig, das wichtigste Kammer und Schluss.
Er hat gesagt, er kann sein Urin nicht halten.
Er ist Inkontinent.
Also eine Harninkontinent.
Das ist eine absolute Indikation für eine...
Was haben wir hier dringende Operationen?
Stuhlinkontinen, Harninkontinen.
Bei Bandscheinvorfall ist eine dringende OP-Indikation.
Also mit wem nicht zu viel zu tun.
Okay, aber kein Problem, deswegen geredieren wir miteinander.
Jetzt machen wir mal Oberarztübergabe.
Und dann können wir uns immer noch unterhalten.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ah, der Herr Kollege, der eifrige Kollege aus der Türkei.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Auch genommen? Ja.
Und ich würde gerne ihn berichten.
Über ihn berichten oder ihn vorstellen?
Friedrich Neumann ist 38 Jahre alt.
1,72 m.
Und 93 kg.
Er hat sich seit heute Mittag...
Seit 3 Tagen bestehende, progrätiere, rechte Beine, Schmerzen.
Schmerzen am besten.
Schmerzen im Bereich rechte Beine.
Die Schmerzintensität seit 8 von 10.
Und die Schmerzen wurden in Gesäß und Fuß ausstrahlen.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, die Schmerzen ist...
Schmerzen strahlen?
Ja, die strahlen in den Fuß.
Ja, strahlen von der Lendenwirbelsäule in den Fuß.
Lendenwirbelsäule, oder?
Und Rücken hat der Patient gesagt.
Ja, ich habe gehört, Po hat gesagt.
Über den Po, genau, über den Plutealbereich.
Ja, in den Plutealbereich und in den Fuß ausstrahlen.
Dagegen habe er über Prof. Prasitamol und Novalgen angenommen.
Aber es zeigte sich unter Medikamente, keine Besserung.
Ja, und der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzentziehende.
Und der Patient, der diese Schmerzen früher noch nicht gehabt.
Noch nie gehabt, okay.
Ja, und der Patient klagt über Parisie, Kraftlosigkeit.
Und der Kribbel auch.
Das ist Parisie oder Kribbel-Parastésie?
Ja, und Sudham gab er auch, er konnte nicht mehr laufen.
Warum?
Ja, er habe starken Schmerzen.
Schmerz bedingt Insomnia und Inkontinenz.
Was war eine Inkontinenz?
Eine Harninkontinenz oder eine Stuhlinkontinenz?
Ja, eine Harninkontinenz.
Seit wann hat er das?
Seit heute Mittag.
Okay, also das ist relativ frisch.
Ja, und in den Vorerkrankungen oder Anvorerkrankungen und Obgeschichte
sein bei ihm nicht bekannt,
nehmen keine Medikamente,
die allergens bei ihm nicht bekannt.
Er hat 3-mal geimpft gegen Covid.
Er hat den Satz richtig gemacht?
Ja, er hat, er sei,
er hat vorstellig gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Vor 6 Wochen,
er ist nach Italien mit seinem Auto gefahren.
Es dauert ungefähr 6 Stunden.
Tabak und Trockenabus wurden verneint.
Alkoholkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese war unaufwärlich.
Er ist seit 10 Jahren Gardner vom Beruf.
Ja, Gardner vom Beruf seit 10 Jahren.
Er hat keine Kinder,
ein Treiber, ein Sport,
ein Besonderes und ein Handball.
Ja, in der Bege...
Auf oder ja?
Ist ja vermutet,
dass er sich alles getrunken hat.
Ja, als diese Anamnestation angaben,
da hat er es dann,
ja,
Sakura Ilja,
Sakura Discarnia.
Ja, oder Kraftlosigkeit.
Oder ist hier,
Spino-Issialzentrum, vielleicht.
Spinalkanal-Schnöze.
Ja, Spinalkanal-Schnöze, in Bedroh.
Ja, als erstes wurde ich körperliche Unterzöpfe.
Danach werde ich rundken
von Lomberbereich veranlösen.
Was noch?
Nur rundken?
Nein, danach MRT.
Und MRT?
Ja, so wie MRT veranlösen.
Was wollen Sie im MRT sehen?
Ja, bei der MRT, ja,
möchte ich,
möchte ich die Weichbereiche oder jetzt Spinalkanale
überprüfen, ob es,
ob es Herr, Herr nicht gibt.
Also Sie wollen schauen, ob ein,
ob ein Bandscheibenvorfall,
ja, ja, ob ein Bandscheibenvorfall,
oder ein Spinalkanal-Schnöze, genau.
Okay.
Und in diesem,
wo machte deine Hahn in Kontinence? Wissen Sie das?
Ja, ja, in der Hahn,
Hahnweg in Kontinence,
oder bei der Hahnweg in Kontinence,
müssen wir sofort,
Nicht Hahnweg, sondern Hahn in Kontinence.
Ja, als Hahn in Kontinence,
sofort operieren,
müssen wir sofort den Patient operieren.
Also Sie meinen,
das kommt durch einen schweren Bandscheibenvorfall?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und was noch?
Ja, ich würde gerne auch
die Neurochirurgische Konzult beantragen.
Ja, aber ich würde erst mal,
also Sie können ein MRT machen, wenn es schnell geht.
Wenn Sie keinen MRT haben, was machen Sie dann?
Was machen Sie dann?
Neurochen, reichten.
Ja, ich denke, Neurochen,
Neurochen ist nicht genug
für diesen Patient,
für diesen Patienten.
Vielleicht CT auch, ja.
An CT ist relativ schnell machbar,
oder sieht man auch schon einige Strukturen ganz gut.
Also wenn ein MRT nicht möglich ist,
dann könnte man schnell eine Computer-Tomographie durchführen.
Okay, gut.
Dann danke ich Ihnen.
Also der Patient kommt,
um es kurz zusammenzufassen,
mit einer akuten Lumborischalgie
und nichts bei einem Bandscheibenvorfall.
Ja, ich höre wahrscheinlich LBK45
und vielleicht S1, S2 auch noch.
Und der Auslöser ist wahrscheinlich
die schwere Arbeit bei der Gartenarbeit.
Okay, gut.
Geht es noch Fragen?
Ich habe nicht gehört Lumborisch.
Also eine Trombose?
Ja, der Patient hat ja die Srucke.
Aber gut, auch eine Trombose muss man denken.
Die Reise hat ein bisschen irritiert, das ist richtig.
Aber es ist eher eine Lumborischalgie.
Und natürlich muss man auch eine Trombose denken.
Das ist richtig.
Aber dann hätte man noch mal die Füße, die wir angucken müssen.
Und das mal anschauen müssen.
Okay, sehr gut.